and we're live welcome everybody to
another hangout super excited to do
another session with you guys I have a
special guest on with me
natasha is writing a book called the
million dollar blog and she asked
interview me and I said I love to happen
to participate why don't we also turn it
into a live YouTube video for people to
join in and ask questions and be part of
the conversation and learn from it as
well so Natasha welcome aboard maybe
just a quick intro of what you're trying
to do for the audience and then take it
away I'm hearing a little bit of you in
the back you may want to just turn down
your speaker volume so that you can it
won't get you won't get or view okay
yeah that's fine
okay perfect so hit me up what's your
what's the first question let's do it
what you do are you that is your website
now the number one website entrepreneurs
in the world how far is it gone so far
um so young Evan Carmichael I believe in
entrepreneurs my my mission is to help a
billion entrepreneurs that's kind of the
big goal that I'm shooting Afghan I
haven't been as attached to the how and
not even so much attached to the number
it's more that the thing that I want to
do is impact a lot of people and so that
impacts the decisions that I make so
will this you know the stuff that I'm
doing today will it enable me to reach
potential millions of people if not and
I'm not interested in doing it and so
the website is one tool I use my youtube
channel is one tool I use my social
media is another tool that I use the
book that I have coming out is another
tool I use and I see it as an all
encompassing kind of strategy to try to
have a big impact in the world of
entrepreneurship and so that's really
every basic question
that's kind of jump inside your head but
this kind of multi-channel philosophy is
that really in fact the kind of way
forward you know ten years ago or five
years ago it's all about websites and
blogs and now there's just so much to
get your head rad is that really
important to you to do everything I
don't think you need to do everything I
think you need to do what's best for you
and for me I've always followed what I'm
interested in and what I love doing it's
I think a business always needs to be an
extension of who you are and what you're
passionate about I think for a lot of
entrepreneurs they start a business and
then they find a way to be successful
with that business and then they change
and go as a person but their business
doesn't change and evolve with them and
that's what you start to get stuck and
you you start looking for distraction
projects and you get bored with your
company and so with the advent of
YouTube and videos I like her to be on
camera
and making videos you want to do this
interview I much rather do it like this
then yes let me list the questions and
I'd type out a response and you know I
don't think it's necessary for everybody
to go and have a YouTube channel and be
active on Instagram and look crazy on
Twitter I think it's just understanding
what you're naturally good at and where
your passion lies and then going all-in
on your strengths and so I'm super
active on YouTube but it's the most
popular channel for entrepreneurs in
terms of subscriber numbers and views
anywhere on YouTube yeah and that's
because I love that art that I'm putting
myself into it so I I go all-in on the
channel I do a lot with the website and
I'm a lot on Twitter what is your
website have a net you know if you're
doing so much on YouTube where does your
website come in could you just ditch
your website and turn it off with that
ridiculous thing to do I could you know
I the website's a part of my business is
a good chunk of my business um I mostly
you know most of my time is spent on the
YouTube stuff and the brands that I'm
working with and a little bit on the
website my team manages most of the
website I think in part because the
content on the web
is not mostly mine I have a thousand
writers who contribute to the website
and so they're adding most of the
content I discovered early on in
creating the the site that one person
who will have a hard time building up a
massive right like I can write three
articles a day and it still wouldn't be
enough because if I want millions and
millions and millions of millions of
views you need to have just a lot more
content that combined with the fact that
I would prefer to do video and do
interviews much more than right yeah so
I'm I'm the I'm the head of the company
and I run it but I have my team do most
of the day-to-day work Internet running
the website this does a lot of
integration though like my youtube
videos are showcased at the top of the
website yeah on my youtube channel I
link back to my website and a sign up so
wherever you have a platform you can use
it to promote the website and vice versa
yeah okay cool so what can we talk about
Nisha and finding a niche how do people
do that what's your advice um bats
how do you define your niche my niche is
entrepreneurs and and it also want to be
entrepreneurs
it's interesting that I I started off
just trying to help entrepreneurs I had
I had a struggle myself in my first
business and have a really hard time
getting my company off the ground and
had you know some of the worst days of
my life trying to figure that out and
and I started this to try to just give
some knowledge back and help other
entrepreneurs not have to go through
that a lot of the people who watch my
stuff and read their website are our mix
between people who want to start a
business and people who are already in
the business we also have a good chunk
of people though who I don't even want
to be entrepreneurs they just like the
positive upbeat message and try to apply
it to their job so you know if I'm
making a some content around Richard
Branson yeah you know they find a way to
make that relevant to their life into
their job even if they have no intention
of starting the business and that was
that was unintended I never thought I
would
an entrepreneur audience all mapped out
from the beginning did you have it all
like laid out on a table this is who I'm
going for when you launched or did you
just know it regardless and kind of
refine it as you went along I am my
market if you look at the people who you
look at the demographics if you get
analytical I'm not the analytical guy
I'm the passion guy I'm the I'm the
heart guy not the head guy I and just
different ways to do it and it's totally
cool just you know knowing my strengths
I'm not the guy who like looks at the
data and looks at the opportunity and
says this is where I'm gonna go yeah I
make things that I love and then I share
it and so if you look at them you look
at my audience if you look at my website
you look at my youtube channel you look
at the people the demographic breakdown
it's mostly people like me so I skewed
towards men over women I the biggest age
demographic is the 30 to 40 range or 25
to 40 range I'm not really five so it's
like that's my since people like me and
so if I create something that I will
love then they will love it too because
I'm like a lot of people who have the
same concerns you can still go into no
game today like new people can still go
way with that philosophy and like
attracting an audience like them because
obviously it's very crowded nowadays
isn't there you know you'd be doing this
for a long time you've got a massive
following what about people coming into
it now can they still go in with that
simple philosophy there is always room
for quality right I mean you're reading
a book right how many books are out
there you know how many how many I don't
want to think of how many books are
published by big publishers let alone
self-publishing
yeah okay why I write a book you know
there's always room for quality so if
you're gonna be a blogger and you're
going to be a solo blogger like you
don't want to have don't want to have
contributors it's just gonna be you know
you take like a goat and kind of
approach yeah it's still you know just
be the expert and provide value if you
can provide value and not just repeat
and copycat what somebody else is doing
but you have a unique
and it's helpful to somebody then that
person is going to come back and that
person is gonna tell their friends and
that person can subscribe to your
newsletter that person's gonna buy your
products there's always room for quality
you know no matter how competitive an
industry is there is always room for
quality I think people will be really
really sure to hear that because it's
very difficult if you're launching now
and you think how do I stand a chance
with all these hugely successful people
so can we just talk about monetization
like what reads you know there's all
these different ways in which nations
are monetized how does the
Entrepreneurship nation work in terms of
monetization there's two main strategies
for anybody who has a website yeah is to
go big and that's when you I want
millions of views millions of people
checking out my content and then you're
playing a game of you know maybe some
clickbait and you know catchy titles and
you're just trying to come up with
strategies to get millions of people to
come and check out your site and that's
often a factor of how much content you
have to write so yeah you need
contributors you need to be you know
thinking one article a day which for
most people would be a lot to post one
yeah now you think you like a hundred a
day right how do I get a hundred
articles a day and so you're you're
pumping an engine up that business model
content content equals traffic yeah I
like the more content the more traffic
is it that simple yeah it's I mean it's
easy quality still plays a very
important part it's not just dumping out
garbage it's got to be good stuff yeah
but but to get like the millions and
millions and millions of views you need
to have a lot of content as well yeah
and so then it's recognized well you
can't write all that content and it's
just figure out what business you want
to be in because in that business now
you're selling advertising you're
selling epic sponsorships you're selling
brand deals with other companies who
want the eyeballs yeah and that's a very
viable legit business model and that's
the model that more the news sites and
Mashable and those kinds of sites go
down that route the second one that more
traditional bloggers go down and I don't
know for the book kind of how you're
defining it but is building a more
personal intimate audience yeah now
you're not selling you could make some
money off advertising stuff but it's
much more
time people to your brand so I'm gonna
sign up for your newsletter I'm gonna
buy your coaching I'm gonna buy your
products I'm gonna buy your book when it
comes out and so it's attaching and
building a personal brand now that's
what people are buying into you and you
don't need to have millions and millions
and millions of views because what
you're counting on is repeat viewers so
yeah the first model you need a lot of
new people coming all the time because
you make money from advertising and they
click on your ads for people who come
back repeatedly they're not going to
click on the ads because they know where
the odds are they know it's an ad and
they click on anymore if you look at
repeat visitors look at the stats they
don't click on ads anymore it's only the
new visitors so if I have a bunch of
repeat visitors coming back to my blog I
may get hundreds of thousands of views
or millions of views but I'm not making
a lot of money because they're all from
the same people and they're not clicking
on that anymore so you monetize it by
having product by having because you
have a loyal connection to them you can
recommend things that I don't I may not
have a personal connection on the first
front like Mashable I may go and check
out but I don't have a personal
connection to Mashable I'm not gonna buy
a Mashable you know hat or t-shirt yeah
you know product but Seth Godin I might
like I'll buy his books and I'll buy a
stuff so it's just either go mass you go
big big pageviews and you build a
business model around that or you go
personal and you make it more niche and
custom and you attract them I'm much
more in the personal camp yeah I mean
products and coaching or what are some
of the things that works for you with
your personal brands um I haven't gone
down the tip of kuru de Guise I don't I
don't want to do coaching I've had a lot
of people ask me for coaching my because
my goal is to help a billion
entrepreneurs coaching doesn't line up
well with that model because it's
one-on-one yeah I don't want to do
one-on-one
sometimes they do for friends or special
people but I don't want to do one-on-one
and so I've turned down a lot of the
opportunities that most people would be
able to have in building a like coaches
whether the number
profit centers for a lot of bloggers and
you make a mastermind group or you make
a private you know session with me
whether it's by Skype or whether it's
you know a retreat that you come to when
you pay five thousand dollars to come
and see me at this place you know that's
a typical higher-end model um I'm just
not I'm not interested in that
I want more impact and so I make my
money through making deals with with
brands yeah but not just selling
eyeballs trying to make a personal
connection so you're in the UK right now
yeah right okay so earlier today I had a
call with Stephen Kelly who's the CEO of
Sage yeah
in London yes I work with him and and
it's all about providing value to
entrepreneurs and we answer questions
for your brand like sage everyone who's
non to preneurmarketing.com
but the way we do it is it is not about
hey Sage software is so amazing go buy
it like a normal brand would want to do
yeah they he wants to be associated with
my brand because I care about
entrepreneurs he cares about
entrepreneurs he wants some of that
goodwill the past onto the hands company
and the next time you you're thinking
about accounting software you think
about sage first because of the value
that he's given and so I work with
brands in that kind of environment where
they're paying me for the goodwill more
than the eyeballs yeah just go buy an ad
but ads aren't working so good luck with
that and I turn away most most brands
and instead only focus on the ones that
really have a mission that aligns well
with what I'm doing so all this comes
back to your own personal brands yeah
and your connection with people so has
that being a strategic you know if you
go online and look about how to do
personal brands there's like notice
graphs and charts and things you can fit
in has happiness a strategic thing for
you will you've done all these exercises
or has it developed organically and
more organically I wish I could say I
was I don't know smart enough to kind of
figure that out but again I'm more of a
lead with the heart guy than head I
understand is a lot of a lot of the
things that go into the brand I've
studied and learned from but the brand
is me and you know thinking about like
believe is the one core word that
represents our brand you know the
airplane means something the the colors
mean something you know we have a
gesture when I own my videos I'll say
continue to believe which is like the
airplane taking off so all the things
that go into branding we've done in
terms of you know font choice name
choice color choice logo you know iconic
sounds you know all of those things that
most branding experts I guess would walk
you through done but it wasn't from the
beginning that I am going to do this and
figure it all out before I start it
happened as I as I built up I think
that's so interesting because you know
even if even as I'm writing this book
and I'm covering personal branding news
I think also now these poor people
reading it gonna have to take and have
it all figured out before they start and
actually people don't have it figured
out before they start do they like
you've kind of adapt it I think that you
don't know and that's what you've found
it is yeah I think in terms of looking
at entrepreneurs a lot of people will
fall into one or two camps you got the
people who who are all they're all
they're in their head they're the
thinkers but then they never actually do
because they're so perfectionist on
getting it right yeah there's always
something else to think about until they
never launch and then you have the
people who just who don't think at all
and just go and those are the guys who
can often flame out and lose all their
money and invest you know take a
mortgage out on their house and you know
go bankrupt and all the horror stories
and where you need to have a little bit
more of both yeah if you're the thinker
you need to have a little bit of courage
to actually do something and if you're
the doer you need to have a little bit
of restraint to like think through a
little bit more and so there are some
people who have both qualities but I've
had a lot of people are lumped into
one of those two groups yeah and it
prevents you from being really great and
that may mean getting a partner that may
mean just having awareness like
self-awareness of what your good and are
that so I've tried to mix III lean
towards the do I like to do stuff I like
the try so I get an idea I'm up doing it
and I will be an army of one and I will
will it into existence you know it's
just gonna happen and it may not be the
highest quality or whatever just just go
just get it started it feels right so
I'm gonna do it and and then the
thinking comes in so like okay I need
I'm building brand assets right so I
need a tagline and I need an logo and I
need font and all that stuff comes in
you know you need a healthy mix of both
and it's stretching your comfort zone to
go after the other when you're so
focused on one yeah so if you were
starting again now from scratch you know
what and you obviously would have to
miss them what are the things you would
do now to kind of propel yourself
forward and develop a personal brand
bearing in mind the things you've learnt
along the way are you talking just in
the blogging world or just in general in
the kind of personal brand world so a
blog would be cut your personal brand so
in terms of the coming known online and
standing out and lying and having your
presence if you're starting from scratch
now yeah I think it's understanding what
you stand for yeah start with that what
do you stand for what's wrong with the
world what's the positive impact that
you want to have and not in the not in
the execution like I feel the world
needs more belief yeah that's a that's a
personal value like you start I believe
everybody has one word that you start
with but whether you get down to one
word or three words or whatever like
start with what you value as a human
being I got this from my parents believe
and they are they are not entrepreneurs
and that's who I believe in people yeah
I can help people through
entrepreneurship because I have
knowledge in that field it's a brilliant
I believe is fantastic on a thing it's
also understanding and so the deeper
exercise for bloggers or entrepreneurs
we're in the book is that it becomes a
tagline that you're marketing yourself
under but it's to you not just a tagline
it's who you are it's deeply personal
and meaningful and it's your core value
and if you can lead with that then for
me I would you know I would I believe in
people in different walks of life if I
didn't know about entrepreneurship when
I knew about making chairs I'd be
believing in people making chairs you
know it's just it's my personality yeah
I bring that to entrepreneurship because
I have expertise in that field so
combining those things what I value with
what I'm good at I can create a personal
brand and so entrepreneurs will watch my
videos and read my content and follow me
on social media all the stuff that
you're supposed to do as a brand because
they want more believe in their life
because they don't have anybody who
believe a lot of people I'm the only one
who believes in them and I've never met
them the only source of inspiration
again is by watching the videos every
day because they have an environment
that isn't conducive to doing something
great even like this shirt that I'm
wearing now we were carrying the little
man and the little man is the hater in
your life the little man sits the person
telling you why you can't be successful
and throwing tomatoes at you and we all
have these doubters and haters around us
and sometimes you are your own little
man
and so it's like triumph over the little
man and this is believed to right I may
not say believe but the message is
believe and so it's on Brad it's part of
the brand and yes so like so maybe maybe
the strategy is make t-shirts to promote
yourself but it just felt I felt like I
wanted I just wanted this so we made it
there's a lot of ways to people to go
out and do it but everything that I
create is about believe and then I
applied to the world of entrepreneurship
but people take this message triumph
over the little man and apply it to
their work life for their professional
career they want to be a figure skater
and they apply it there to the people
who hate on
right so the message is much more
powerful but I try to keep to the world
of entrepreneurship just because that's
what I'm good at
so if you are starting a brand it has to
start at the core of something that you
powerfully believe in like the big
impact you want to make on the world
what's wrong with the world right now
what's the one core value that you stand
for you know you have always stood for
you always will stand for and then apply
it to an industry that you have this is
like this thinking it through way that I
didn't do but if I talk through it what
I did yeah you know then you apply to an
industry that you're passionate and have
some knowledge in and it's really
interesting that you didn't do it but
your tagline has become so important and
actually is at the heart of what you do
so it's kind of even though you didn't
do it it's great you've done it now like
it's obviously run through everything
you do the word believe' yeah this this
or this there was a massive struggle for
me because I was trying to come up with
what a tagline was and I think if I had
some of the tools and resources and this
is part of what I cover in my book it
would have been faster and easier for me
yeah my tagline for the longest time was
motivation and strategies for
entrepreneurs yeah tell us it tells you
what I do and that's that most people do
you know motivation is strategies for
entrepreneurs or whatever it is that
you're about but it's boring like
everybody says that it doesn't have an
emotional connection and I didn't like
my tagline but I didn't know why and I
didn't know how to change it and so it
came through a lot of self-discovery and
I didn't I didn't really maybe I read
the wrong books or I don't know I
couldn't I couldn't figure out why I
didn't like it or how to fix it and so I
met with some friends of mine and the
Steve Jobs movie out to the first one
with Ashton Kutcher how to had a big
impact on me um and then I just started
writing down a list of different ideas
that I liked and believe was one of them
but I thought it's too short like
believe is too what does that mean you
know you know so I have to be more
specific and then I get back the next
day and I like I like believe more like
people but it's got
like I believe in entrepreneurs or
believe in your dreams okay and then the
more you add stuff to it like I don't
like any of those things and that just
settle down and believe and I so I'm
sure with the right coach or the right
resources that I didn't have I could
have got there faster but I just
everyone building a personal brand needs
a tagline I don't you know I think I
think I see when you say tagline what
what I think of is like a marketing
positioning statement is like an
external thing for people to understand
what you're about and I think it helps I
think having a website helps I think
having a youtube channel helps I think
having Twitter helps I think you know
all of these things can help at the core
though what you should start with is not
not see the world from an external like
how people gonna see me but how do you
see yourself yeah it starts inside
what's the value that you must believe
in and then you can create that through
a tagline through a YouTube channel
through a website through all these
different mechanisms so as a tagline
important yes because you want people to
be able to talk about you in an easy way
but yeah people say oh you still gotta
go do for motivation and strategies for
entrepreneurs it's like this huge
mouthful that nobody's ever gonna say
and so you know you want a message that
is easy for people to talk about but at
the core of it I think is even more
important because it doesn't just
influence your value doesn't just
influence your your tagline but it
influences every decision that you make
in your business yeah okay brilliant
and if someone's thinking you know I
can't do it because I'm new and it's
people like Evan out there he's been
doing it for years and I can never run
it half the other successful personal
brand online I'm too far behind what
would you take them and you would say
probably believe right uh it's actually
part of it I think I think what helps is
to a couple things one do it because you
want to do it enjoy the creation not the
result so yeah as an example I will
throw away more things than most people
make so you know
an example so work with sage on a as a
client
I designed a series of ads for them that
were visionary that I love that I think
they should run with but they never will
I know they will never run with it I
knew going in that they would never use
this but I still spent you know two or
three hours making them yeah because it
was a niche like I had to make it
because maybe they learn something in
the process a little bit of Education
but it was for me to create it it was in
my head I'm driving home from taking my
parents to the airport I had to make it
and so it's it's enjoying the process of
doing it not just I'm not gonna be happy
till I reach a billion entrepreneur's
you it's never you know it's never gonna
be there so that I think is important
you're doing it because you love to do
it
the second thing is don't compare your
start to somebody else's middle yeah you
look back on my channel if you look at
my youtube channel it's I sucked at the
start I was terrible it's bad it's
really really really bad it took me
seven hundred videos until I wasn't
embarrassed by myself I couldn't watch
my own videos back I was embarrassed to
go oh look at that so bad it's so bad
and how do you know people struggle to
keep going right that's the point at
which many people give up yeah they
listen I've got the cringe I'm in
amazement I manage myself I give up and
they throw that toys out of the pram how
did you keep going through with that one
because I knew the way I enjoyed it
right one is I enjoy if you don't enjoy
it huh you're not gonna make so I've
made three thousand videos now but you
know you're not gonna enjoy making seven
hundred videos if all you're focused on
is I want to be a superstar on it be
well know and I want people to know my
name that's not enough to get you
through all the crap that you have to go
through yeah enjoy the process of
building it and so I'd like make it even
though I was embarrassed by myself I
couldn't watch them back I like the
process of doing it and I focus on being
better than I was the day before so why
not my sucked and then
great at 700 right like there was a it
was a process to get better and better
and better every time and it took me
thirteen hundred videos until I
motivated myself like I watched the
video like Wow though you know thirteen
hundred videos though and seven hundred
just to not be embarrassed and so I see
people who are maybe like five videos in
yeah and they're like oh I'm so bad look
at how bad I am and and if I showed you
my fifth video you're way better than I
was five videos in like way better and
they give up because they don't love it
enough and so those two things like
you're enjoying the process and to your
focus on getting better every day
and stop comparing yourself to your
start that somebody else's middle yes
there's always somebody better than you
and if all you're looking at is it's
great to use them as inspiration and
ideas and motivation but that the
downside is like I can never be you know
if I look up and in the speaking world
you know maybe I look at Les Brown I
love Les Brown I can never be like Les
Brown so now I'm gonna stop speaking no
I'm gonna find I'm gonna be the best
Evan Carmel I can be and I can take some
of that from Les Brown and from from
other people and as long as I feel like
if you feel like you're growing you're
gonna be happy you're gonna keep going
the minute you feel like you're not
growing or learning anymore it's over
you're gonna you lose your passion you
don't want to do it anymore
yeah thank you so much
do you think people would ask any
questions yeah so we've got come out I
know we're kind of tired of the time but
let's get the amount who wrote in to say
he's from London so this is London in
the house fifteen years old asking how
do I find a good mentor Kaji find a good
mentor what does come out what to do can
he access ah come out if you want
already what you're doing are you pretty
strong say seven you made more than me
about hats fundamental both answer
both do it okay well I've always looked
for mentors who I think are kind of like
me but where I want to be so I had a
mentor when I was running a previous and
my previous online business which is a
press agency here in London I had a
mentor he was 10 years older than me and
had three kids and had an amazing house
and had a swimming pool and I thought
that's the right sort of mental for me
because it's someone I can look to is
where I'd like to be 10 years in the
future so I always think it's important
to be invented by someone who seems like
you but ahead yeah I love it and so he
wrote back to say technology and I asked
what kind of technology so we can get a
better sense but what I look for I mean
I echo that I think you want to find
find knowledge that exists in other
people that you want to learn from and
part of it might be business so like
this person is a great businessman and
or this person you know has a great
relationship with with his wife and I
love that too and maybe he knows nothing
about business but I want to bring that
and learn from him yeah and so it's
finding those people and then one
reaching out right like even what we're
doing right now you know latasha's right
in the book she wants some advice on how
to be how to build successful brand
maybe part of its her curiosity to to
build her own brand and she reached out
to me and other people and it's gotten
some greedy eyes on how to do it right
oh yeah people are willing to help and
give feedback and advice if you reach
out yeah that's training the second
point I would add on that is I benefited
a lot from aspirational mentors to
people that that I've never met and
never will meet some of them are dead
but I've learned a lot from them and so
you know I learned a lot from Steve Jobs
well we'll never meet I learned a lot
from Richard Branson who I have not met
yet my favorite entrepreneur is AP
Giannini who most people haven't heard
of and I learned a lot from him
I learned from Walt Disney you know I
learned from yeah I think that's true
and I think I'm ticketed come out you
know teenager it might be you know he
might I don't know his school
something to find and fundamental but
there's always there's so many books
like my bookshelf there is packed with
six experts and stories of entrepreneurs
and those the books I've read since 2008
you know the whole time I thought in my
previous business and now said those are
always creative ailable and really
readable and great fun and really
inspirational yeah I think a lot of
people I appreciate their I'd mentor
super helpful super important but don't
feel like well there's nobody in my city
who you know is it could be a good
mentor there's nobody my family who
could mentor me I don't know who to
reach out to and then let that stop your
search because there's a lot of great
information in books or on YouTube
videos or in articles or in
documentaries or in magazines that you
can learn from and surround yourself
with that and pull from them Bill Gates
save my business even though I've never
met him because how he built Microsoft
was a model that I used to build my
software company out from nothing and so
like I owe a lot of credit to him even
though he has no idea who I am
he's my mentor - he needs some believe
but yeah so I love the idea of
traditional mentors definitely very
helpful but I also encourage you to look
at aspirational mentors cool I know
we're a little bit over I gotta hop on
to know their calls thank you guys so
much for watching
Natacha fact for people to find out more
about you and the book which isn't out
yet but what's the best way to do that
and the book is already available for
pre-order on Amazon it's called the
million dollar blog it's being published
including Amazon September the 27th yeah
and corneas and a wire at the end which
I and a wine I'll put the link to her
site in the description so you guys can
just paste it there but I should thank
you so much
no worries great she thank you so much
thank you guys for watching and continue
to believe and we'll see you soon